My friend Etgar, his mom does not take no for an answer. Etgar's Israeli. Etgar Keret, we run his short stories here on the radio show now and then.
我的朋友埃特加，他的母亲是不达目的誓不罢休的人。埃特加是以色列人。埃特加·凯雷特，我们现在偶尔会在广播节目里播他的短篇小说。
Anyway, years ago, Etgar's older brother was in the army serving in Lebanon. Israel had just invaded Lebanon. It was war.
总之，多年前，埃特加的哥哥在黎巴嫩服兵役。以色列当时刚刚入侵黎巴嫩。那是战争时期。
And it sounds incredible to us, but the policy of the Israeli army is that if it's at all possible, you go home on leave every two weeks. And Lebanon's close, just next door to Israel. Etgar says his brother was coming home every month. And then that stopped. He wasn't getting any leave.
这对我们来说简直不可思议，但以色列军队的政策是，如果可能的话，每两周就要回家休假一次。黎巴嫩离以色列很近，就在隔壁。埃特加说他哥哥每个月都会回家。后来这种情况停止了。他再也没有得到任何假期。
And my brother didn't come home for almost two months, and it drove my mother crazy. And she decided that she should get my brother back home. And it's very difficult to deal with anything during the war, because everybody is hysterical and crazy.
我哥哥有近两个月没回家，这让我母亲快疯了。她决定要把哥哥带回家。在战争期间处理任何事情都非常困难，因为每个人都处于歇斯底里和疯狂的状态。
But she decided that she needs to speak to the chief of staff. And she started calling--
但她决定她需要和参谋长谈谈。于是她开始打电话——
And the chief of staff is the head of the army?
参谋长是军队的最高领导吗？
Yeah, it's like the head general.
对，就像总将军一样。
For the entire army?
是整个军队的？
Yeah.
没错。
Etgar explained her strategy was simple. She'd call the guy's office, talk to whoever answered.
埃特加解释说，他母亲的策略很简单。她会打给那家伙的办公室，跟接电话的任何人谈。
And she would talk for long enough until she would have something that she could say offended her or made her angry. And then she asked to speak with that person's superior.
她会一直说，直到找到能让她觉得被冒犯或让她生气的话题。然后她就会要求与其上级通话。
She did the same thing with that person and then that person's superior.
她对那个人也如法炮制，然后再找那个人的上级。
And so on and on and on and on. And in the end, she found herself speaking to the head general, Rafael Eitan, who is one of Israel's most famous kind of war heroes.
就这样一次又一次。最终，她直接和总将军拉斐尔·埃坦通上了话，他是以色列最著名的战争英雄之一。
And she said to him, listen, General Eitan, I know that you're fighting a war. And I really don't want to waste any of your time, so I will make it simple. My son didn't get a leave from the army for the past two months.
她对他说，听着，埃坦将军，我知道你在打仗。我真的不想浪费你的时间，所以我简单说。我儿子过去两个月没从军队得到假期。
I give you 24 hours to send him back home. If you know what's good for you, he'll be back before tomorrow evening.
我给你24小时把他送回家。如果想对自己好点，他明天晚上之前就得回来。
Wait, if you know what's good for you?
等等，如果想对自己好点？
Yeah. And the guy says to her, I just want to understand, Mrs. Keret. Are you threatening me? And she says, yes, I am. I'm threatening you. And I didn't want to put it in the subtext, because I know that you're busy. So if you know what's good for you, you'll send my son back home.
对。那家伙对她说，我只想确认一下，凯雷特太太。你在威胁我吗？她说，是的，我是在威胁你。我不想使用潜台词，因为我知道你很忙。所以如果想对自己好点，你就把我的儿子送回家。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he says to her, Mrs. Keret, do you know who I am? And she said, yeah, you're Rafael Eitan, the war hero. And he said to her, if you know anything about me, then you know that I'm not easily scared.
他对她说，凯雷特太太，你知道我是谁吗？她说，知道，你是拉斐尔·埃坦，战争英雄。他说，如果你了解我，你就知道我没那么容易被吓倒。
So my mother said, yeah, but I don't think you had many chance to fight with elderly Holocaust survivors, who are 5 foot tall and weigh 82 pounds. And I want to tell you something, and I'll make it very simple and very quick. After you quit the army, you either go to politics or you go to the free market.
于是我母亲说，是啊，但我认为你以前没多少机会和那些身高5英尺、体重82磅的老年大屠杀幸存者交手。我想告诉你一件事，我会说得非常简单和迅速。你退役后，要么从政，要么去自由市场。
In both cases, you're going to be very exposed. In both cases, every time, there'll be a TV camera around or journalist. You'll have this elderly lady sitting in the first row, shouting at you, accusing you of any bad things that you might have made and maybe of some bad things that you've never made. Because I'm a very good liar. And you really don't want that. And at that stage, he hung up the phone in her face.
在这两种情况下，你都会暴露在公众视野下。在这两种情况下，每当有电视摄像机或记者在场时，我这个老太太就会坐在第一排，对你大喊大叫，指责你可能犯下的任何坏事，甚至指责你从没做过的坏事。因为我非常擅长撒谎。你真的不想那样。在那一刻，他挂断了她的电话。
The next afternoon, Etgar's brother arrived home. So they pulled him out of his ranks, told him to get on a helicopter. He had no idea what was going on, nor did anybody else.
第二天下午，埃特加的哥哥到家了。他们把他从队伍中拉出来，让他坐上直升机。他根本不知道发生了什么，别人也都不知道。
He assumed some family member died or something, Etgar says. And he got his break.
埃特加说，他以为家里出了什么事或者有亲戚去世了。他就这样得到了假期。
He came and took a shower, slept for 16 hours. My mother saw that he was OK. And a day after that, he went back to Lebanon.
他回来洗了个澡，睡了16个小时。我母亲看到他没事。一天后，他又回到了黎巴嫩。
I should say, we cannot confirm the details of this story, including the dialogue between Etgar's mom and Rafael Eitan. This happened over 30 years ago. Eitan's dead. When we got Etgar's mom, she said, sure, whatever Etgar says.
我得说，我们无法确认这个故事的所有细节，包括埃特加的母亲和拉斐尔·埃坦之间的对话。这发生在30多年前。埃坦已经去世了。当我们联系到埃特加的母亲时，她说，当然，埃特加怎么说就是什么。
But there are many stories of Etgar's mom doing things like this. There was a time she threatened a mugger so effectively that he abandoned the idea of mugging her in the middle of the mugging. There was a showdown with the president of Poland that ended when the president of Poland finally gave her the passport she demanded, as somebody who had been born in Poland.
但是埃特加的母亲做这类事情的故事有很多。曾有一次她威胁了一个劫匪，效果好到他在抢劫过程中放弃了抢劫她的念头。还有一次与波兰总统的对峙，最后以波兰总统交出她要求的护照而告终，因为她是在波兰出生的。
Etgar is the same way in certain situations. He doesn't threaten. That's not who he is. He just reasons people to death.
埃特加在某些情况下也是如此。他不会威胁别人。那不是他的性格。他只是用道理把人说死。
Case in point, a couple of years ago, he and his wife Shira and their then 8-year-old son, Lev, were traveling, and they left a backpack on an airplane. In the backpack was Etgar's iPad, which had all of his son's games on it.
举个例子，几年前，他和妻子希拉以及当时8岁的儿子列夫在旅行时，把一个背包落在飞机上了。背包里有埃特加的iPad，里面有他儿子所有的游戏。
Lev had spent months on his games working his way up the levels of the games. Now, that was gone. Lev was really messed up about it. Any parent knows what I'm talking about.
列夫花了几个月的时间玩他的游戏，一路打通关。现在，全没了。列夫对此感到非常崩溃。任何父母都知道我在说什么。
And they called the airline. The airline says, no problem. When you get to the airport for the return flight, go to lost and found. It'll be there.
他们给航空公司打了电话。航空公司说，没问题。当你回到机场乘返程航班时，去失物招领处就行了。它会在那里的。
So comes the day. They're on their way home. They get to the airport. This is in Rome. They can't find the lost and found. Time is getting short. They've got a plane to catch.
终于到了那天。他们在回家的路上。他们到了机场。这是在罗马。他们找不到失物招领处。时间越来越紧。他们还要赶飞机。
Finally, a guy at the car rental-- super nice guy-- offers to take them to it.
最后，租车处的一个家伙——人超级好——主动提出带他们过去。
His name was Massimo. And he took us to the lost and found place, where there was this really, really nasty woman. And I said to her, you know you have our bag. And we're supposed to take it, and we're going to fly really soon.
他叫马西莫。他带我们去了失物招领处，那里有一个非常、非常刻薄的女人。我对她说，你知道你有我们的包。我们需要拿回它，我们很快就要飞走了。
I said to her, I can actually see it. And I pointed to the bag, because it was behind her.
我对她说，我其实能看见它。我指了指那个包，因为它就在她身后。
She says to Etgar, she needs a letter from the airline saying he was on the same flight as the backpack. Etgar doesn't have this letter.
她对埃特加说，她需要航空公司的一封信，证明他和那个背包在同一架航班上。埃特加没有这封信。
She said, sir, I'm not going to give you the bag without the letter. I'm sorry. And I said to her, but I go to Israel. I never get to see the bag. And she said, you know, that's your problem.
她说，先生，没有那封信我是不会把包给你的。很抱歉。我对她说，但我回以色列了。我再也见不到那个包了。她说，你知道，那是你的问题。
As somebody who knows Etgar, I'll just say, wrong move. Something deep and powerful kicks in inside him.
作为一个了解埃特加的人，我只能说，选错对手了。他体内深处某种强大的东西被激发了。
My wife said to me, OK, let's go, so we won't miss the flight. I said, no, just a moment. And I said to the woman, look, don't give me the bag, but just do this kind of thing.
我妻子对我说，好了，我们走吧，免得错过航班。我说，不，等一下。我对那个女人说，看，别把包给我，但请做一件小事。
Please, unzip the outside pocket of it, and see if there are crackers in it with a Hebrew writing on the package of crackers. And she said, why would you want to do that? I said to her, I just ask you to please do it.
请拉开包的外侧口袋，看看里面有没有饼干，包装上有没有希伯来文。她说，你为什么想让我这么做？我对她说，我只是请求你这样做。
And she went and said, yeah, there are crackers in it. So I said to her, so we both agree that this is my bag? She says, yeah, this is your bag. So I said to her, so would you please give it to me?
她走过去说，没错，里面有饼干。于是我对她说，那么我们都同意这是我的包，对吧？她说，对，这是你的包。我接着说，那你愿意把它给我吗？
She said, no, sir, I won't give it to you, unless you give me this letter. And I said to her, but you understand that my son is here, and his game is here. Are you a parent? And she said, yes, I'm a parent.
她说，不，先生，除非你给我那封信，否则我不会给你的。我对她说，但你明白我儿子在这里，他的游戏在这里。你是父母吗？她说，是的，我是个母亲。
And I said to her, so think about it. If your son had a game he really wanted to win, you had to go and confront with the person who said, yeah, I know this game is yours. But your son is never going to get it just because of some kind of technicality. You're Italian. Be Italian. Be warm, be nice, be like in a Fellini movie. Give me the bag.
我对她说，那就想想看。如果你儿子有一个他非常想赢的游戏，你不得不去面对一个说，是啊，我知道这是你的游戏，但因为某种技术性问题，你儿子永远也得不到它的人。你是意大利人。发挥你的意大利风情。热情一点，友善一点，就像在费里尼的电影里一样。把包给我。
And she said, no, sir. I'm not going to give you the bag, and you're wasting your time. You better go to your flight, because you're going to miss your flight. And Shira said, let's go. She isn't going to give it to you.
她说，不，先生。我不会把包给你的，你是在浪费时间。你最好去赶你的航班，否则你会误机的。希拉说，我们走吧。她不会给你的。
And I said to her, but don't you understand, as a human being, there will be one day when you die, and you look back at your life, and you think about this day. And when you think about this day, you'll think about this father who came with a child. And basically, technically, you could solve all the problems, but you chose to stick with some kind of technicality. Would that be a nice dying thought to leave the world with?
我对她说，但你不明白吗，作为一个人类，总有一天你会死去，当你回顾一生时，你会想到这一天。当你想到这一天时，你会想到这个带着孩子的父亲。其实，从技术上讲，你可以解决所有问题，但你选择固守某种条文。作为离开世界时的临终念头，这真的好吗？
And she was beginning to say, sir, I'm not going to give you anything. But as she was about to say that, Massimo, the guy from the car rental, jumped over the counter, picked up the bag. And she said to him, what are you doing?
她刚想说，先生，我什么都不会给你的。但就在她要说出口时，租车处的马西莫跳过柜台，捡起了那个包。她对他说，你在干什么？
And he said to her, I can't take it anymore. And he jumped back over the counter, and he gave me the bag. And she said to him, if you don't get the bag back, I'm going to call airport security, and they're going to arrest you.
他说，我受够了。他跳回柜台，把包给了我。她对他说，如果你不把包还回来，我就要叫机场保安了，他们会逮捕你的。
So I said to him, look, it's not a good solution. Take the bag. And Massimo said to me, look at me. Do as I say. Run.
于是我对他说，听着，这不是个好办法。拿着包。马西莫对我说，看着我。照我说的做。快跑。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
These things happen so often that Etgar's wife, Shira, worries that someday, somebody is just going to go nuts on Etgar or something, hurt him.
这种事情发生得太频繁，以至于埃特加的妻子希拉很担心哪天有人会因为埃特加而疯掉，或者伤害他。
There are situations when my wife just says to me, just shut up. Shut up. Shut up now. Don't talk about it anymore. Shut up.
有些时候我妻子只是对我说，闭嘴。闭嘴。现在闭嘴。别再提这事了。闭嘴。
And I always listen to my wife. But when it starts, I can't stop it. But at the same time, I'll say to myself, I'm this asshole, who just keep arguing and doesn't move on. And I really think that this has to do with something very kind of primal that when I was a little child, my parents were both Holocaust survivors.
我总是听我妻子的。但一旦开始，我就停不下来。但与此同时，我会对自己说，我就是个混蛋，只会不停地争论，不肯罢休。我真的认为这与某种非常原始的东西有关，因为我小时候，父母都是大屠杀幸存者。
They kind of raised me to say people are good. But sometimes, they don't get it that they're good. So you have to kind of tell them things a few times, maybe slap them around a little. And then they understand that they're good. And then they're going to listen, and everything's going to work.
他们养育我的方式是，人本性是善良的。但有时他们不明白自己是善良的。所以你得告诉他们几次，也许扇他们几下。然后他们就会明白自己是善良的。然后他们就会听话，一切都会顺利。
Well, today, on our program, we have a story about somebody else who can't help himself. He sees something he needs to fix, he needs to take care of, he needs to make it right. And then through sheer force of will, he makes things happen boldly, heroically. Though is it heroic if you can't stop yourself?
好了，今天在我们的节目中，有一个关于另一个无法控制自己的人的故事。他看到需要修复、需要处理、需要纠正的事情，他就会通过纯粹的意志力，大胆地、英雄般地让事情发生。虽然，如果你无法停止自己，这还能算英雄吗？
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1, Loudspeaker.
第一幕，扩音器。
So we start today with a guy, who-- I don't want to overstate this, and it sounds really big when you say this out loud, but I really think it might be the truth-- a guy who, with sheer force of will, utterly changed our politics and created the political world we live in today, alongside a second man who helped him. Zoe Chace tells the tale.
今天我们要从一个人开始，我不想夸大其词，说出来听起来可能很严重，但我真的认为这可能是事实——一个凭借纯粹的意志力彻底改变了我们的政治，并创造了我们今天所生活的政治世界的人，他与另一个帮助他的人一起。佐伊·蔡斯讲述了这个故事。
It's probably helpful in telling this story to remember for a second what politics was like before today-- how different, informal, and quaint things used to sound.
在讲这个故事时，回顾一下今天之前的政治是什么样子的或许会有帮助——过去的事情听起来是多么不同、随和而古雅。
This is President Reagan walking onto the South Lawn. It's 1983, April, but apparently, a cold day. One of the lawmakers is looking very Soviet in his big coat and fur collar.
这是里根总统走上南草坪。那是1983年4月，但显然是个冷天。其中一位议员穿着大衣，带着皮领，看起来非常苏联。
Well, I want to extend to all of you a very warm welcome. Something ought to be warm.
那么，我想向你们所有人表示最热烈的欢迎。总得有什么东西是温暖的。
Reagan's in this '70s, all brown suit, with a brown tie.
里根穿着那身70年代的全棕色西装，打着棕色领带。
But it's especially fitting that so many of us from so many different backgrounds-- young and old, the working and the retired, Democrat and Republican-- should come together for the signing of this landmark legislation.
但我们中有这么多来自不同背景的人——年轻人和老年人，在职者和退休者，民主党人和共和党人——能够齐聚一堂签署这项具有里程碑意义的立法，尤为贴切。
Social security legislation, a major bipartisan compromise involving raising taxes and cutting spending to things that only go together when it's a bipartisan compromise.
社会保障立法，一项重大的两党妥协，涉及加税和削减开支，这只有在两党妥协时才会同时发生。
And now, as a special treat, I would like to ask two of our leaders from Congress. First, to step forward for a few words is Speaker of the House of Representatives, the honorable Tip O'Neill.
现在，作为一份特别款待，我想请我们国会的两位领导人。首先，请众议院议长、尊敬的蒂普·奥尼尔上前致辞。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Thank you, Mr. President. Mr. President, Mr. Vice President, my distinguished colleagues in government, this is indeed a happy day.
谢谢你，总统先生。总统先生、副总统先生、我在政府中受人尊敬的同僚们，这确实是快乐的一天。
A special treat, the Democratic leader. The friendship between Ronald Reagan and Tip O'Neill is one of the most famous friendships in American politics. These days, it's regularly trotted out, like a fable, to demonstrate what the good old days were like back when things worked.
一份特别款待，民主党领导人。罗纳德·里根和蒂普·奥尼尔之间的友谊是美国政治中最著名的友谊之一。这些日子，它常被像寓言一样拿出来，展示过去的美好时光，那时事情是如何运转的。
If you knew anything about Speaker of the House Tip O'Neill, you know he was a bipartisan schmoozer, a big Muppety guy, who took up a lot of space in the room. He'd invite members from both parties to poker nights in DC. He was in Congress for decades and by the time he was Speaker, he was a living legend type.
如果你了解众议院议长蒂普·奥尼尔，你就知道他是一个喜欢两党交际的人，一个大块头，在房间里占据了很大的空间。他会邀请两党的成员参加华盛顿的扑克之夜。他在国会待了几十年，到他担任议长时，他已经是个活着的传奇了。
We got along. And Nancy and I had Tip and his wife over for dinner.
我们相处得很好。南希和我还请蒂普和他的妻子来吃过晚餐。
This is Reagan talking to William F. Buckley.
这是里根在和威廉·F·巴克利谈话。
Then one day, I picked up the paper and read where he had made a statement about me that was pretty harsh. And I called him, and I said, Tip, I thought we had a relationship here, where we could do business together. And, oh, now, I read in the paper that you said--
有一天，我拿起报纸，读到他对我发表了一番相当严厉的言论。我给他打电话，说，蒂普，我以为我们之间有种关系，我们可以一起做生意。噢，现在，我在报纸上读到你说——
And he interrupted me and said, well, buddy, that's just politics. He said, after 6 o'clock, we're buddies. We're friends. I did take it that every once in a while, when we had a meeting, I would visibly set my watch at above 6 o'clock.
他打断我说，好吧，伙计，那就是政治。他说，6点之后，我们是哥们。我们是朋友。我确实认为，偶尔我们开会时，我会明显地把表调到6点之后。
To be fair, O'Neill had been known to call Reagan a real Ebenezer Scrooge. Truth is, their relationship was complicated. They disagreed profoundly about a lot of stuff.
平心而论，奥尼尔曾被称为真正的“埃比尼泽·斯克鲁奇”。事实上，他们的关系很复杂。他们在很多事情上存在深刻分歧。
But that's the point. It's why people tell each other this story. The two were able to come together and talk, compromise, and pass legislation. Anyway, here we are today.
但这正是重点。这就是人们互相讲述这个故事的原因。两人能够走到一起并交谈、妥协、通过立法。总之，我们今天到了这里。
The MS-13 lover, Nancy Pelosi.
MS-13的爱人，南希·佩洛西。
People are mean about each other now in public, all the time, in particular, the president. And of course, people fight back. This is Congresswoman Maxine Waters.
人们现在在公共场合对彼此都很刻薄，一直如此，特别是总统。当然，人们会反击。这是国会议员玛克辛·沃特斯。
He's not a role model for our children. He is a liar. He's a con man.
他不是我们孩子的榜样。他是个骗子。他是个诈骗犯。
Maxine Waters, a very low IQ individual. You ever see her? And Conor Lamb-- Lamb the Sham, right? Lamb the Sham.
玛克辛·沃特斯，一个智商很低的人。你见过她吗？还有康纳·兰姆——“冒牌兰姆”，对吧？冒牌兰姆。
Lamb the Sham never caught on. But you know what I'm talking about. It's different now.
“冒牌兰姆”没叫响。但你知道我在说什么。现在不同了。
Here, I want to lay out for you one theory of the case as to how we got from there to here. We've always had two parties. But we didn't always have two teams like we do now.
在这里，我想为你们列出一种关于我们如何从那时走到今天的理论。我们一直有两个政党。但我们并不总是像现在这样拥有两个对立的团队。
Red versus blue, us versus them. Each side routinely demonizes the other side as un-American. You sign up for one issue-- the wall, the Mueller investigation, Colin Kaepernick, climate change-- you basically sign up for all of them.
红色对抗蓝色，我们对抗他们。每一方都习惯性地将另一方妖魔化为反美。一旦你支持某一个议题——边境墙、穆勒调查、科林·卡佩尼克、气候变化——你基本上就支持了所有议题。
It wasn't always so zero sum like it's become. You could explain what happened in different ways. But I'm going to argue it was the work of these two guys that got us to this point, two guys, one quarterbacking the other.
过去并不总是像现在这样零和博弈。你可以用不同的方式解释发生了什么。但我认为正是这两个家伙的工作让我们走到了这一步，两个人，一个指挥另一个。
And so without further ado, ladies and gentlemen, the first of the two men who created the modern world. You know him from Fox News. You know him from Republican primaries gone by, former Speaker of the House Newt Gingrich.
那么，事不宜迟，女士们先生们，创造现代世界的两个人中的第一位。你们在福克斯新闻上认识他。你们在过去的共和党初选中认识他，前众议院议长纽特·金里奇。
I hope I can convey this in a way that you can really feel. If we lose, we will be able to look our children and our grandchildren in the face and say, we did everything we could to save this country.
我希望我能以一种你们真正能感受到的方式传达这一点。如果我们失败了，我们将能够面对我们的孩子和孙子，并说，我们为了拯救这个国家尽了一切努力。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Gingrich was a weird, nerdy kid growing up. People close to him say he always pictured himself as a historical figure, someone who would bend the course of American history, someone who anticipated stories like the one I'm telling you now. From his teenage years, he thought this way.
金里奇在成长过程中是个奇怪、书呆子气的孩子。亲近他的人说，他一直把自己设想为一个历史人物，一个将扭转美国历史进程的人，一个预见到我正在讲述的这种故事的人。从青少年时期起，他就这样想了。
He ran for Congress twice in West Georgia, lost, and then finally won a seat in the House in 1978 with a 1778 attitude, like there was a revolution on, and the country's very existence was at stake. We're fighting a war, Gingrich said back then, a war for power. Raise hell. Raise hell all the time.
他在西乔治亚州竞选了两次国会议员，都失败了，直到1978年终于赢得了一个众议院席位，带着一种1778年的心态，好像革命正在发生，国家的生存岌岌可危。金里奇当时说，我们正在进行一场战争，一场权力战争。去闹吧。一直闹下去。
His goal was to retake the House of Representatives. At the time, an impossible dream. Republicans had been in the minority for 24 years. People called it the permanent Democratic Congress.
他的目标是夺回众议院。当时，这是一个不可能的梦想。共和党人已经有24年处于少数地位了。人们称之为“永久的民主党国会”。
Once Newt finally got there, he discovered, as he'd suspected, was a place full of losers with Stockholm syndrome. It was chummy, mostly guys in suits and ties, smoking cigars, playing poker together and generally, getting along, hanging out, talking to each other. Also, depending on your perspective, it was a corrupt cesspool of bribes and giveaways. That's definitely how Gingrich saw it.
纽特终于到了那里后，他发现，正如他所料，这里充满了患有“斯德哥尔摩综合征”的失败者。这里很亲密，大部分是穿着西装、打着领带的家伙，抽着雪茄，一起玩扑克，总体上相处得很好，一起消磨时光，互相交谈。此外，根据你的角度来看，这是一个腐败的贿赂和赠品窝点。这绝对是金里奇眼中的样子。
Republicans didn't have much power, but they'd go along to get along and occasionally do some deals. And most of them had stopped imagining it could be any other way. I learned most of this story from the great political reporter Steve Kornacki. He'd just published a book about this time called The Red and The Blue: The 1990s and the Birth of Political Tribalism. He's also that excited guy at the big board on MSNBC during elections.
共和党人没什么权力，但他们会随波逐流，偶尔做些交易。他们中的大多数人已经停止想象会有其他方式了。我从伟大的政治记者史蒂夫·科纳基那里学到了这个故事的大部分内容。他刚出版了一本关于那个时代的书，叫《红色与蓝色：1990年代与政治部落主义的诞生》。他也是选举期间在MSNBC大屏幕上那个兴奋的家伙。
His arrival in the House coincides with a historic moment in the house, and that is the first television camera is placed in the chamber in 1979-- his first year there. And its C-Span.
他的到来恰逢众议院的一个历史性时刻，那就是1979年——他到任的第一年——第一个电视摄像机被安装在了众议院。这就是C-Span。
C-Span may not sound exciting to you, but A, it's still awesome. And B, it's a major change. Now anyone can see for themselves what's going on in Congress if they want to. And people in Congress can speak to anyone on the outside.
C-Span对你来说可能听起来不怎么令人兴奋，但第一，它还是很棒的。第二，这是一个重大的改变。现在，如果人们愿意，任何人都能亲自看到国会里正在发生什么。而且国会里的人也可以跟外面的任何人对话。
Newt gets it right away. The rest of the House does not.
纽特立刻明白了。众议院的其他成员没有。
There's a lot of opposition to it, because this is a club here. But once the camera's there, most members, they just kind of ignore it. And they leave at the end of the business day. And they go and they do whatever it is they do after business hours.
有很多反对意见，因为这里是一个俱乐部。但一旦摄像机在那里，大多数成员，他们只是忽略了它。他们在工作日结束时离开。然后去做他们下班后做的事。
To Newt Gingrich, here it is. I want people to notice this around the country. I got an audience now.
对纽特·金里奇来说，就是这个。我想让全国各地的人注意到这一点。我现在有听众了。
Yeah, it's Twitter.
是的，这就是推特。
The gentleman from Georgia, Mr. Gingrich, is recognized for 60 minutes.
来自乔治亚州的金里奇先生，获得60分钟发言时间。
Thank you, Mr. Speaker. I want to pick up where Mr. Walker left off on the document entitled What's the Matter with the Democratic Foreign Policy by Mr. Frank Gregorsky.
谢谢你，议长先生。我想从沃克先生刚才关于弗兰克·格雷戈斯基题为《民主党外交政策出了什么问题》的文件结束的地方继续讲起。
OK, not Twitter exactly. He's professorial, pedantic, not a lot of flair.
好吧，不完全是推特。他像个教授，迂腐，没什么天赋。
Somehow, someday, this country has got to learn to live with revolution in the third world. It's endemic.
总有一天，这个国家必须学会与第三世界的革命共存。这是地方性的。
And he starts claiming there's this rule in the house that at the close of business and any day, any member can claim the floor for any reason they want for pretty much any amount of time they want. And it's called special orders. And Gingrich starts claiming these special order speeches that were 10 o'clock at night, 11 o'clock at night.
他开始声称众议院有一条规定，在任何一天的闭会时，任何议员都可以以任何理由、在相当长的时间内要求发言。这被称为“特别命令”。金里奇开始要求这些晚上10点、11点进行的特别命令发言。
It's an empty chamber. His colleagues are asleep. They're drinking. They're not there. They're not listening to this. They're never even going to hear about this-- most of them. But Gingrich knows there are people all across America, who've got these new cable boxes in their house, who are scanning the dial and seeing what's out there.
这是一个空荡荡的议事厅。他的同事们在睡觉。他们在喝酒。他们不在那里。他们没有听这些话。他们甚至永远不会听说这些——他们中的大多数人。但金里奇知道，全美各地都有人，他们的家里装了这些新的有线电视盒，正在扫描频道，看看有什么节目。
And some of them are going to pause when they see him. And what they're hearing is he's not giving a dry speech about and now, if I can direct your attention to subsection 3 of the agriculture funding-- he's giving these grand speeches about American politics, and an American identity, and the corrupt Democrat machine.
其中一些人会在看到他时停下来。他们听到的是，他不是在发表干巴巴的演讲，比如“现在，如果我能引导你们关注农业资助的第3小节”——他正在发表关于美国政治、美国身份以及腐败的民主党机器的宏大演讲。
Often Gingrich or one of his few allies was explaining how the Democrats were fringy, communist radicals. The whole party, everyone in the party was, more or less, a socialist. It was sort of his version of all Democrats want open borders, but less punchy.
金里奇或他的少数盟友经常解释民主党人是如何边缘、共产主义的激进分子。整个政党，党内的每个人，或多或少都是社会主义者。这有点像他的版本，“所有民主党人都想要开放边境”，只是没那么有力。
Since communism doesn't strike them as an independent, inexorable force, feeding on totalitarian personalities and concepts, McGovern Democrats don't fear it. Trash America, indict the president, and give the benefit of every doubt to Marxist regimes. That's the standard formula.
由于共产主义在他们看来不像是一种独立的、不可阻挡的力量，以极权主义人格和概念为食，麦戈文民主党人并不害怕它。诋毁美国，起诉总统，并把所有的好处都给马克思主义政权。这是标准公式。
He is producing what you would now recognize as a cable news show on the floor of the House. And he's performing for the camera, and he's giving his monologue. He's giving his monologue on the decay of the Democratic Party, the decay of American culture, the promise of a Republican Party that embraces opportunity and responsibility, and all these things.
他正在制作一个你现在会认为是众议院议事厅里的有线电视新闻节目。他在为摄像机表演，他在发表独白。他在就民主党的衰落、美国文化的衰落、拥抱机会和责任的共和党的前景等所有这些事情发表独白。
And there is an audience that starts to tune in. And he knows it. He gets that. He gets the potential of that before anybody else.
而且开始有听众收看了。他知道这一点。他得到了。他在任何人之前就意识到了这一点。
Newt believed there was a Republican majority out there. Because just a decade earlier, Richard Nixon had trounced the Democratic candidate for president. He won 49 out of the 50 states. Clearly, there was an appetite for Republican rule.
纽特相信外面有一个共和党多数派。因为就在十年前，理查德·尼克松击败了民主党总统候选人。他赢得了50个州中的49个。显然，人们对共和党统治有胃口。
But Republicans were still a minority in the House. People somehow weren't syncing up their Republican votes into one Republican ticket. What he needed to do was paint all the Democrats more clearly as the enemy to the voters. And he'd do that by associating all of them with a candidate who'd lost to Nixon-- George McGovern.
但共和党在众议院仍然是少数。人们不知何故没有把他们的共和党选票整合到一张共和党票上。他需要做的是向选民更清楚地把所有民主党人描绘成敌人。他会通过将他们所有人与那个输给尼克松的候选人——乔治·麦戈文联系起来来实现这一目标。
George McGovern was sort of the Bernie Sanders of his day. So lefty, he even freaked out a lot of Democrats in '72-- the counterculture, anti-war candidate.
乔治·麦戈文有点像当年的伯尼·桑德斯。太左了，甚至在72年吓坏了很多民主党人——反主流文化、反战候选人。
If Republicans were able in 1972 to score that epic of a landslide running against the Democratic Party of George McGovern and the activists behind him, Newt Gingrich believed that's the key to the Republican Party winning everything. If you nationalize politics, and you make voters everywhere in the country see in whatever Democrat it is in their backyard, who's running for whatever office it is-- Congress, or Sheriff, or state legislature, or dog catcher-- if you get the voters to see that Democrat as no different from George McGovern and the folks around him, well, you know how those voters are going to react.
如果共和党人在1972年能够通过反对乔治·麦戈文的民主党和背后的活动人士而取得那样的压倒性胜利，纽特·金里奇相信这就是共和党赢得一切的关键。如果你将政治全国化，让全国各地的选民在他们后院里竞选任何职位的民主党人身上——国会议员、治安官、州立法委员或捕狗官——如果你能让选民看到那个民主党人与乔治·麦戈文和周围的人没有什么不同，那么，你知道那些选民会如何反应。
They're going to go, and they're going to vote Republican. And so his idea was to make voters across the country judge politics based on what they saw coming out of Washington, based on what they saw coming out of the national media.
他们会去投票，投给共和党人。所以他的想法是让全国各地的选民根据他们从华盛顿看到的情况、根据他们从国家媒体看到的情况来评判政治。
Based on what they saw on C-Span, where over and over again, Newt brought up McGovern.
基于他们在C-Span上看到的情况，纽特一遍又一遍地提到麦戈文。
In the late '60s and early '70s, it became a truism with the entire American left from bomb throwers in Chicago, to eastern writers, to progressive, pinstriped supporters of Eugene McCarthy and McGovern. The Southeast Asia would be fine once the US left.
在60年代末和70年代初，这成为整个美国左派的真理，从芝加哥的炸弹投掷者，到东部的作家，到尤金·麦卡锡和麦戈文的进步派、穿条纹西装的支持者。东南亚在美国离开后会很好。
Attacking congressmen by congressmen by name and footnotes.
通过名字和脚注攻击国会议员。
Congressman Harkin, on June 26, 1979 told the house that the Sandinistas knew more about nurturing democracy than America did. Quote, "should the United States feel empowered to meddle once again in Nicaragua?"
哈金议员在1979年6月26日告诉众议院，桑地诺民族解放阵线比美国更了解如何培育民主。引用，“美国是否应该感到有权再次干涉尼加拉瓜？”
This speechifying made the Speaker of the House furious. You remember the Speaker, the affable Muppet, Tip O'Neill. Newt Gingrich and a couple of the other guys, Gingrich acolytes, are talking smack about specific congressmen. They're questioning their patriotism on the public record, and they aren't even there to respond.
这种演讲让众议院议长非常愤怒。你还记得那位议长，和蔼可亲的木偶，蒂普·奥尼尔。纽特·金里奇和其他几个家伙，金里奇的追随者，在说具体的国会议员的坏话。他们正在公开记录中质疑他们的爱国主义，而这些人甚至不在那里回应。
That was not done. It was against the gentlemanly code of the House. As Speaker, Tip O'Neill controls the cameras. And he orders them to pan out and show the empty room that Gingrich and his buddies are addressing.
这是不允许的。这违反了众议院的绅士准则。作为议长，蒂普·奥尼尔控制着摄像机。他下令将镜头拉远，展示金里奇和他的伙伴们正在对着空无一人的房间讲话。
Bob Walker, Republican from Pennsylvania, happens to be speaking right then. And he takes great umbrage when this happens.
来自宾夕法尼亚州的共和党人鲍勃·沃克碰巧正在讲话。当这种情况发生时，他感到非常愤怒。
But I do want to take a note of something that's evidently happening right now, which is a change of procedure here.
但我确实想注意一下显然现在正在发生的事情，那就是这里的程序发生了改变。
Tip O'Neill thinks this will make the guys look petty talking to no one. Watching it, it's like a surreal Beckett play. A tiny man at the bottom of the screen gestures wildly from a podium as though he's speaking to a big crowd, but he's surrounded by empty chairs.
蒂普·奥尼尔认为这会让这些家伙看起来在对着空气说话很卑鄙。看着它，就像一出超现实的贝克特戏剧。屏幕底部的一个小人对着讲台疯狂地做手势，好像在对一大群人讲话，但他周围是空的椅子。
It is my understanding that as I deliver this special order this evening, the cameras are panning this chamber, demonstrating that there is no one here in the chamber to listen to these remarks. That is evidently the work of a change in the pattern of rules around here. It is one more example of how this body is run, the kind of arrogance of power that the members are given that kind of change with absolutely no warning.
据我理解，当我今晚进行这个特别命令时，摄像机正在扫描这个议事厅，证明这个议事厅里没有人听这些言论。这显然是这里规则模式改变的结果。这是这个机构如何运作的又一个例子，给予成员那种傲慢权力的例子，这种改变竟然没有任何预警。
I see the gentleman from California, Mr. Coelho, was standing in the back of the chamber just a moment ago. Mr. Coelho has talked in recent weeks about shutting off these special orders and not allowing them to even be seen in the countryside. And he stands in the back of the chamber now smiling.
我看到来自加利福尼亚州的科埃略先生刚才站在议事厅后面。科埃略先生在最近几周谈到过要关闭这些特别命令，甚至不让它们在乡下被看到。他现在站在议事厅后面微笑着。
I have to feel that perhaps he is getting worried that some of the things that are being said in this chamber in these special orders are, in fact, influencing people out across the country to think that this body is something less than what the American people think it ought to be.
我不得不认为，也许他开始担心在这些特别命令中在这个议事厅里说的一些话，实际上正在影响全国各地的人们认为这个机构不如美国人民认为的那么好。
Lots of C-Span watchers today understand the congressmen are putting on a performance. There isn't always someone in the audience. But it was new back then.
今天许多C-Span的观众明白国会议员是在表演。观众席上并不总是有人。但在那时这是新鲜事。
This all sets up a wild showdown between Newt and the Speaker Tip O'Neill. A few days later, Gingrich gets time on the floor.
这一切为纽特和议长蒂普·奥尼尔之间的一场狂野摊牌做了铺垫。几天后，金里奇在议事厅获得了时间。
OK, I'll be delighted to yield to our distinguished Speaker if he wishes to continue this.
好的，如果我们的杰出议长愿意继续，我很乐意让给他。
The Speaker of the House Tip O'Neill asking Gingrich to yield, so he can say something. And Newt does, knowing the Speaker is going to yell at him. This time, the chamber is packed with congressmen and reporters both. Here's Tip O'Neill.
众议院议长蒂普·奥尼尔要求金里奇让位，以便他能说些什么。纽特照做了，因为知道议长会冲他大喊大叫。这一次，议事厅里挤满了国会议员和记者。这是蒂普·奥尼尔。
My personal opinion is this. You deliberately stood on that well before an emptied House and challenged these people. And you challenge their Americanism. And it's the lowest thing that I've ever seen in my 32 years in Congress.
我的个人观点是这样的。你故意站在那个空无一人的众议院前，挑战这些人。你挑战他们的美国精神。这是我在国会32年来见过的最卑鄙的事情。
Mr. Speaker, if I may reclaim my time.
议长先生，如果我可以收回我的时间。
As insults go, in the US House, circa 1984, this is big, so big, Trent Lott, Republican from Mississippi, standing near the Speaker says, I move we take the Speaker's words down.
在1984年左右的美国众议院，侮辱言论是非常严重的，严重到来自密西西比州的共和党人特伦特·洛特站在议长附近说，我动议把议长的话记下来。
I move we take the Speaker's words down.
我动议把议长的话记下来。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
This means that would Tip O'Neill just said to Gingrich is so offensive, so toxic that he wants the wrongness of it officially acknowledged, perhaps even struck from the historical record as though it had never been said. For five full minutes, everyone shuffles around, clutching their pearls about Newt, about the Speaker's behavior, how do we preserve the dignity of the House.
这意味着蒂普·奥尼尔刚才对金里奇说的太冒犯、太有毒了，以至于他希望官方承认其错误，甚至从历史记录中删除，就好像它从未被说过一样。五分钟里，每个人都走来走去，对纽特、对议长的行为表示震惊，我们如何维护众议院的尊严。
The clerk reads out the offending speech once again so that the Chair can decide what to do about it.
书记员再次读出冒犯性的讲话，以便主席可以决定如何处理。
The Chair feels that type of characterization should not be used in a debate.
主席认为那种描述不应该在辩论中使用。
This is like saying, that was out of line. Don't do that again. That was very bad. But it doesn't actually erase the words from the historical record. Still, it was an epic showdown. Speaker of the House Tip O'Neill being scolded in front of America.
这就像说，那太过分了。别再那样做了。那非常糟糕。但这并没有真正从历史记录中删除这些词。尽管如此，这还是一场史诗般的摊牌。众议院议长蒂普·奥尼尔在美国面前被训斥。
Maybe it's hard to understand what a coup this is for a younger congressman. But think of him as a producer, a producer of his newly-formed experimental cable news show on C-Span, how expertly produced this moment was.
也许很难理解这对一个年轻的国会议员来说是一场多么大的政变。但把他想象成一个制作人，一个他在C-Span上新成立的实验性有线电视新闻节目的制作人，这一刻制作得多么专业。
Everyone's in the room. The Speaker of the House basically promotes Gingrich's late night program. Then the Speaker gets called out in front of the whole country, and he looks arrogant and mean. And Newt Gingrich is at the center of the room, like a conductor, pointing from one guy to the next guy, doling out time, as the Speaker gets red in the face and yells over the room.
每个人都在房间里。众议院议长基本上为金里奇的深夜节目做了宣传。然后议长在全国面前被点名，他看起来傲慢而刻薄。纽特·金里奇处于房间的中心，像个指挥家，从一个人指到下一个人，分配时间，而议长脸红脖子粗地对着房间大喊大叫。
Does the gentleman from Georgia yield?
来自乔治亚州的绅士让位了吗？
The gentleman, Mr. Weaver--
这位绅士，韦弗先生——
[BANGS GAVEL]
[敲槌声]
Does the gentleman yield?
这位绅士让位了吗？
[BANGS GAVEL]
[敲槌声]
And the gentleman, Mr. Walker, if they would express their opinion to the members of the floor, it would be fine.
如果韦弗先生和沃克先生能向议员表达他们的意见，那很好。
Point of parliamentary inquiry.
程序询问点。
And the story is covered on the nightly news. This is a turning point for Newt Gingrich. He's now the Pied Piper, and other Republicans start rallying to his causes.
这个故事在晚间新闻中进行了报道。这是纽特·金里奇的一个转折点。他现在是“花衣魔笛手”，其他共和党人开始聚集到他的事业中。
Not long after this episode, Tip O'Neill retires. And he's replaced by Speaker Jim Wright. Newt sees an opening to take Wright down. He thinks it'll rally the Republicans in the House. It's a battle they can win.
在这个事件后不久，蒂普·奥尼尔退休了。他被议长吉姆·赖特取代。纽特看到了拉下赖特的机会。他认为这会团结众议院的共和党人。这是一场他们能赢的战斗。
Wright is both cocky and dismissive of the minority party, with none of the hail buddy Tip O'Neill warmth. It'll be a branding exercise for the new aggressive Republican Party Newt was selling.
赖特既自负又轻视少数党，没有蒂普·奥尼尔那种哥们儿般的温暖。这将是对纽特正在兜售的新型激进共和党的一次品牌推广活动。
Here's what happens. He reads a story in the Washington Post about the new Speaker getting $0.50 on the dollar for every one of his books he's selling. It's more of a pamphlet than a book, actually, but it's a way to give the congressman backdoor donations. The people buying it were like the local Teamsters in his district and supporters at rallies.
发生了什么事。他在《华盛顿邮报》上读到一篇报道，关于新任议长每卖出一本书就能得到五毛钱。其实比起书，这更像是一本小册子，但这是给国会议员后门捐款的一种方式。购买它的人就像他选区的地方卡车司机和集会上的支持者。
Newt talks to the papers about this, compares Wrights to Mussolini, makes speeches. Think of it as though he's standing on his tiptoes, shouting over the heads of Congress to the American people-- drain the swamp. That's his intention.
纽特向媒体谈到这一点，将赖特比作墨索里尼，发表讲话。想象一下，他踮着脚尖，越过国会对着美国人民大喊——排干沼泽。这是他的意图。
Again it's just the idea that here's this clubby, elite, arrogant institution that the corrupt Democrat machine is powering. And they are so disdainful of you everyday Americans that this is how they behave. And so Gingrich is calling for an ethics committee investigation on the House Speaker.
这再次只是这个想法，这里有一个权贵、精英、傲慢的机构，腐败的民主党机器正在驱动它。他们对你们这些普通美国人如此蔑视，以至于这就是他们的行为方式。所以金里奇要求道德委员会对众议院议长进行调查。
It's like shooting the general. The code of the House is you don't do this.
这就像射杀将军。国会的准则是你不这样做。
Newt's striking at the top of the food chain. It's brazen. I want to say here, as tactical as Gingrich's attack on Wright was, from one perspective, this was an attack on corrupt, lazy Democrats that was long overdue. It felt idealistic for everyone sick of being pushed around in the minority.
纽特正向食物链顶端出击。这很无耻。我想在这里说，纽特·金里奇对赖特的攻击在战术上有多么精明，从一个角度来看，这是对腐败、懒惰的民主党人的一次早该进行的攻击。对于所有厌倦了在少数派中被排挤的人来说，这感觉很理想主义。
Gingrich promised a new system that was less corrupt, more transparent, more accountable to the voters, not just like we're putting on a play that we're two parties. But at 6:00 PM, we dropped the mask and make it work. Democrats freaked out when this happened, but Republicans were getting into it.
金里奇承诺了一个新的体系，不那么腐败，更透明，对选民更负责，不仅仅是我们像在演戏，我们是两个政党。但在下午6点，我们摘下面具让它工作。民主党人在这种情况发生时吓坏了，但共和党人开始加入了。
It's not like Gingrich launched the campaign, and the entire Republican Party signed the letter, and that's it. But they didn't pull him aside and say stop. And I think, even a couple of years earlier with Tip O'Neill, that would have happened.
并不是说金里奇发起了竞选，整个共和党都签了名，就是这样。但他们没有把他拉到一边说停止。我想，即使是几年前对蒂普·奥尼尔，那种事也会发生。
Newt gets his ethics investigation into the Speaker's behavior. Wright defends himself petulantly on the House floor.
纽特对议长的行为进行了道德调查。赖特在众议院议事厅里发脾气地为自己辩护。
It is true, I think, the people on my staff were eager to sell these books. I've got to accept some responsibility for that if it was wrong. But the rule doesn't say it was wrong.
确实，我想，我工作人员中的人急于卖这些书。如果是错的，我必须承担一些责任。但规则并没有说这是错的。
It's kind of, yes, I had a private email server, but it wasn't that big a deal. You know by now how that goes over. After an investigation, the most powerful man in the House, who had served for 34 years, is forced to resign. Wright gives a speech on the House floor that reminded me of Jeff Flake retiring from the Senate last year.
这有点像，是的，我有私人电子邮件服务器，但没那么大不了。你现在知道那是什么感觉了。经过调查，众议院最有权势的人，服务了34年，被迫辞职。赖特在众议院发表了一次演讲，让我想起了去年从参议院退休的杰夫·弗雷克。
And it is grievously hurtful to our society when vilification becomes an accepted form of political debate, negative campaigning becomes a full-time occupation, when members of each party become self-appointed vigilantes carrying out personal vendettas against members of the other party.
当诋毁成为政治辩论的可接受形式时，当消极竞选成为全职职业时，当每个政党的成员成为自封的治安官，对另一政党的成员进行个人报复时，这对我们的社会造成了严重的伤害。
And he frames it in terms of something wrong is happening in this institution.
他将其框定为这个机构内正在发生错误的事情。
In God's name, that's not what this institution's supposed to be all about.
以上帝的名义，那不是这个机构应该代表的全部。
When I came here, a congressman's word was a congressman's word, and that mattered for something. When I came here, we didn't question each other's honor. I mean, it's all subtext to all of this. He's not using his name, obviously, but the subtext to all of this is, this is Newt Gingrich.
当我来到这里时，国会议员的诺言就是国会议员的诺言，那是有分量的。当我来到这里时，我们不会质疑彼此的荣誉。我的意思是，这都是这一切的潜台词。显然他没有用他的名字，但这一切的潜台词是，这就是纽特·金里奇。
Harsh personal attacks on one another's motives and one another's character drown out the quiet logic of serious debate on important issues. Surely, that's unworthy of our institution.
对彼此动机和性格的严厉人身攻击掩盖了关于重要议题的严肃辩论的平静逻辑。当然，这不配我们的机构。
Jim Wright painted his resignation as a sacrifice on the altar of civility. He seemed to think his resignation would be so dramatic, it would put an end to the wars Gingrich had started in the House. Obviously, the opposite is true.
吉姆·赖特将他的辞职描绘成文明祭坛上的牺牲。他似乎认为他的辞职会如此戏剧性，以至于会结束金里奇在众议院发起的战争。显然，事实恰恰相反。
Republicans in Congress are galvanized by Wright's fall and Newt's tactics to get him out. The wars that Gingrich dreamed of are starting to materialize. Newt becomes the second most powerful Republican in the House, and he starts making himself into a franchise in the mid '80s.
国会的共和党人受到赖特倒台和纽特让他下台的策略的鼓舞。金里奇梦寐以求的战争开始实现了。纽特成为众议院第二大权势的共和党人，他在80年代中期开始将自己变成一个特许经营权。
He starts running this organization called GOPAC. It's basically a candidate training organization and fundraising tool. That's where he develops these audiotapes, little by-mail cassette tapes that teach potential candidates how to do Newt's divisive brand of politics. John Boehner has talked about driving around, listening to tapes like this in the car.
他开始经营这个叫GOPAC的组织。它基本上是一个候选人培训组织和筹款工具。他就是在那里开发了这些录音带，通过邮寄的盒式磁带，教潜在候选人如何做纽特这种分裂性的政治品牌。约翰·博纳谈到过开车时听这样的磁带。
I don't want to repeat it. But I will just say, I have said this now for six months. And every audience I say it to nods yes and understands. You cannot maintain civilization with 12-year-olds having babies, 15-year-olds shooting each other, 17-year-olds dying of AIDS, and 18-year-olds getting a diploma they can't read.
我不想重复它。但我只想说，我已经这样说了六个月了。我说的每一位听众都点头表示理解。你无法维持一个有12岁生孩子、15岁互相射击、17岁死于艾滋病、18岁拿着看不懂的毕业证书的文明。
And I stop audiences and say, now, if you disagree with that, and you think you can maintain a civilization with those things going on, the rest of what I'm going to say is irrelevant. You're not us. I don't want to waste your time.
我停下来对观众说，现在，如果你不同意这一点，认为你可以维持一个有这些事情发生的文明，那么我接下来说的一切都不相关了。你们不是我们。我不想浪费你们的时间。
You're not us. You're on one team or the other. So that's a lot. Gingrich is almost at the height of his power. He has an army of Republicans falling in line using the same language that they're going into battle-- he has media attention.
你们不是我们。你们要么在这边，要么在那边。所以那很多。金里奇几乎处于权力的巅峰。他有一支共和党军队在排队使用相同的语言，他们正在进入战斗——他有媒体关注。
But it's the same old, entrenched Democratic Congress. The Republicans keep winning these big presidential victories, but the House is stuck with that permanent Republican minority. That's when the second guy comes into this story, the guy that made Newt Gingrich's dreams finally come true.
但这仍然是那个根深蒂固的民主党国会。共和党人不断赢得这些巨大的总统胜利，但众议院被困在那个永久的共和党少数派中。那是第二个家伙进入这个故事的时候，那个让纽特·金里奇的梦想最终成真的人。
And no, I don't mean Democratic President Bill Clinton, though, you could certainly argue that that is why Newt gets his wish. But something happens before that-- someone.
不，我不是指民主党总统比尔·克林顿，尽管你可以肯定地辩称这就是纽特如愿以偿的原因。但在此之前发生了什么——某人。
This is a man, who, I think, has had an astonishing impact on America. He is, in many ways, the quintessential American.
这是一个我认为对美国产生了惊人影响的人。在许多方面，他是典型的美国人。
Here's Newt Gingrich introducing him at a training event for Republican candidates in 1995.
这是纽特·金里奇在1995年为共和党候选人培训活动介绍他。
One of the reasons I believe in the end we'll win is the person who's about to talk to you. We now have a media giant who stands astride the entire of society. Join me in welcoming a man who is creating the 21st century-- Rush Limbaugh.
我相信我们最终会获胜的原因之一是即将与你们交谈的人。我们现在拥有一个跨越整个社会的媒体巨人。请和我一起欢迎一个正在创造21世纪的人——拉什·林博。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Rush Limbaugh was the perfect tool for Newt's mission. He and Newt had basically the same views. But Rush was outrageous and exciting. He made his listeners feel like they were part of a righteous underground movement, the only people who were still sane in a world gone crazy and stupid.
拉什·林博是纽特使命的完美工具。他和纽特基本上有相同的观点。但拉什是令人震惊和兴奋的。他让他的听众觉得他们是一个正义的地下运动的一部分，是在一个变得疯狂和愚蠢的世界里唯一仍然理智的人。
Thank you. Thank you very much. Nice to be with all of you extremists tonight.
谢谢。非常感谢。今晚能和你们这些极端分子在一起真好。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's nice to be with like-minded souls, who want to starve our children and get our old folks sick and dying in the gutter. It's so nice to be with so many of you. I could just look out there. I see in so many hearts and faces the desire to poison the water and the air. Gee, isn't it great to be together here tonight?
能和志同道合的灵魂在一起真好，他们想要饿死我们的孩子，让我们的老人在阴沟里生病死去。能和你们这么多人在一起真好。我只要向外看。我在这么多心中和脸上看到了毒害水源和空气的渴望。天哪，今晚能在一起真好，不是吗？
Rush's communications' ambitions were just as high as Newt's political ones. He never wanted to be in politics. He just wanted to make the greatest radio show ever.
拉什的传播抱负和纽特的政治抱负一样高。他从来不想从事政治。他只是想制作有史以来最伟大的广播节目。
Half my brain tied behind my back just to make it fair. It's The Rush Limbaugh Program. From New York and our flagship station--
大脑的一半绑在背后只是为了公平。这是拉什·林博节目。从纽约和我们的旗舰电台——
He set the standard for political talk radio. And of course-- wait, I have it right here-- widely imitated. Rush was funny.
他设定了政治脱口秀广播的标准。当然——等一下，我这里就有——被广泛模仿。拉什很有趣。
Did you know that the White House drug test is a multiple choice test?
你知道白宫药物测试是一个多项选择测试吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He could also be cruel. He said things like if you don't want to get AIDS, don't have gay sex. He was heavily anti-political correctness. He ended up acting almost as Newt's de facto interpreter. He zhuzhed up his message.
他也可能很残忍。他说过诸如“如果你不想得艾滋病，就不要进行同性性行为”这样的话。他严重反对政治正确。他最终几乎充当了纽特的事实上的翻译。他让他的信息变得更时髦。
Rush doesn't sound like a nerdy YouTube professor. Gingrich talked about saving America from liberal politicians. But Limbaugh sharpened the Us vs. Them. Democrats were about this. Republicans were about that. This is from Rush's TV show.
拉什听起来不像一个书呆子气的YouTube教授。金里奇谈到从自由派政治家手中拯救美国。但林博加剧了“我们对他们”。民主党人是关于这个的。共和党人是关于那个的。这是来自拉什的电视节目。
All right, Zoe Baird is in big trouble. She's been nominated as attorney general, but as you all know, she hired some illegal aliens to take care of her kids. Now, she only makes $660,000.
好了，佐伊·贝尔德有大麻烦了。她被提名为司法部长，但正如你们所知，她雇佣了一些非法外籍人员来照顾她的孩子。现在，她年薪只有66万美元。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
As Cokie Roberts of ABC says, she had the best line. With that kind of money, she could hire Mary Poppins. Why is she out there hiring illegal aliens? Now, I have a couple of points about this I want to make that I don't think anybody else has made, except me in other places. In case you haven't heard it, you should hear it, because it's brilliant points.
正如ABC的科基·罗伯茨所说，她有一句最好的台词。有那么多钱，她本可以雇佣玛丽·波平斯。她为什么要雇佣非法外籍人员？现在，关于这一点我想提出几点，我认为除了我在其他地方提到的，没有人提出过。如果你还没听说过，你应该听听，因为它是天才的观点。
Bill Clinton's nominee for attorney general, Zoe Baird, hired an undocumented immigrant as a nanny for her kids, didn't pay social security taxes. At the time, I was 11. I remember it well. She was the only other Zoe I'd ever heard of. So I was thrilled.
比尔·克林顿提名的司法部长佐伊·贝尔德雇佣了一名无证移民作为她孩子的保姆，没有缴纳社会保障税。当时我11岁。我记得很清楚。她是除了我以外我听过的唯一的佐伊。所以我很激动。
Zoe paid the money back after she was nominated. And neither Senate Democrats or Republicans saw it as a big deal at first.
佐伊在被提名后补缴了钱。参议院民主党人和共和党人起初并不觉得这有什么大不了的。
But Newt Gingrich, that's the nerve of politics that Newt Gingrich is just conditioned to look for. And it's like, God, could it be any bigger? You've got a Democratic president coming in. And for attorney general, the top law enforcement officer in the country, he's nominating a woman who just blatantly flouted social security taxes.
但纽特·金里奇，那是纽特·金里奇被调教得寻找的政治神经。就像，天哪，还能更大吗？你有一位即将上任的民主党总统。对于司法部长，国家的最高执法官员，他提名了一个公然无视社会保障税的女人。
It's just that populist nerve of they get away with things you don't. They live lives of privilege you can't imagine. They lord it over you. They don't have to worry about the things you worry about. It touched all of those nerves. Gingrich got it immediately. He's railing against this. Limbaugh got it immediately. He's railing against this.
这正是那种“他们可以逃脱你不能逃脱的事情”的民粹主义神经。他们过着你无法想象的特权生活。他们骑在你头上。他们不必担心你担心的事情。它触动了所有这些神经。金里奇立刻明白了。他对此大加抨击。林博立刻明白了。他对此大加抨击。
And what happens is the senators, who are in the committee and don't feel this immediately, they start feeling it because their phones start ringing off the hook. There are Democrats who start saying after a couple of days that their office calls are, like, 90 to 1 against Zoe Baird's confirmation.
发生的事情是，那些在委员会里没有立即感受到这一点的参议员们，他们开始感受到了，因为他们的电话开始响个不停。几天后，有民主党人开始说，他们的办公室电话比率是90比1反对佐伊·贝尔德的确认。
I mean, this is widespread. And then they feel the pressure. They feel the pressure that Gingrich and Limbaugh had stoked. And it kills the nomination.
我的意思是，这是广泛的。然后他们感受到了压力。他们感受到了金里奇和林博激起的压力。这杀死了提名。
When Newt needed to communicate something to voters, he now had a direct line to millions of them listening to Rush every afternoon.
当纽特需要向选民传达某些事情时，他现在有一条直达数百万每天下午听拉什的人的路线。
One afternoon, I'm in the middle of a big fight here. And I called Rush Limbaugh's program director, and I said, here is exactly what's going on. He turned on C-Span. He could see what was going on. It was an issue they cared about. And Rush went straight into talking about it. He's got somewhere between-- I don't know-- 4 and 14 million people. It's a lot, and they're intense.
一天下午，我正处于一场大战斗中。我给拉什·林博的节目主管打了电话，我说，这就是正在发生的事情。他打开了C-Span。他能看到正在发生的事情。这是一个他们关心的问题。拉什直接开始谈论它。他有大约——不知道——400万到1400万人。很多，而且他们很狂热。
An hour later, I had members walking up to me on the floor saying, what did you do? Because literally, in some places, their phones are so jammed, they couldn't use them.
一小时后，我在议事厅里有成员走到我面前说，你做了什么？因为字面上看，在某些地方，他们的电话堵得太厉害，他们用不了。
That's from the documentary Rush Limbaugh's America. It describes how Newt would just fax talking points out to talk show hosts around the country. It was like he was calling in airstrikes.
这是来自纪录片《拉什·林博的美国》。它描述了纽特是如何把谈话要点传真给全国各地的脱口秀主持人的。就像他在呼叫空袭。
I want to read to you now a paragraph from a letter that Newt Gingrich sent to all Republican members.
我现在想给你们读一段纽特·金里奇发给所有共和党成员的信中的一段。
Newt wasn't just stirring the pot with divisive politics. He did have a policy vision. He got people to unite under it. Going into the 1994 midterm elections, hundreds of Republican candidates signed on to this thing-- the Contract with America. For a moment, they were all literally on the same page with Newt Gingrich.
纽特不仅仅是在用分裂性的政治搅浑水。他确实有一个政策愿景。他让人们团结在它之下。在1994年中期选举中，数百名共和党候选人签署了这个东西——《与美国契约》。有那么一刻，他们字面上都和纽特·金里奇站在同一页上。
The contract promised to fix everything they thought had gone wrong after 40 years of one-party control of the House. There were anti-corruption measures targeted at the Congress itself, plus a slate of 10 proposals to balance the budget, cut welfare, do tougher sentencing, lower taxes, basically, a limited government, law-and-order agenda. They ran the contract in full in an ad in TV Guide, because everyone read TV Guide, and they'd open it up several times a week.
合同承诺修复他们认为在40年单一政党控制众议院后出错的一切。针对国会本身的反腐败措施，加上10项平衡预算、削减福利、更严厉的量刑、降低税收的提案，基本上是一个限制政府、法律与秩序的议程。他们在《电视指南》的一则广告中完整地刊登了合同，因为每个人都读《电视指南》，他们每周会打开它几次。
And with that, Newt Gingrich, of course, got his majority, like he'd always dreamed, and became Speaker of the House in 1995. He moved into the office held by Jim Wright and Tip O'Neil before him. Here's Democrat Dick Gephardt handing over the gavel.
随之，纽特·金里奇当然得到了他梦寐以求的多数派，并于1995年成为众议院议长。他搬进了在他之前的吉姆·赖特和蒂普·奥尼尔持有的办公室。这是民主党人迪克·格普哈特交出木槌。
With resignation, but with resolve, I hereby end 40 years of democratic rule of this House.
带着辞职，但带着决心，我在此结束众议院40年的民主党统治。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Newt Gingrich pledges to work across the aisle, as they always do, though, for the first time, Republicans don't have to. It's an epic hugely significant victory. Though it was Newt's dream, many people called it the Limbaugh Congress.
纽特·金里奇承诺跨党派合作，就像他们一直做的那样，尽管，这是第一次，共和党人不必这样做。这是一场史诗般意义重大的胜利。尽管这是纽特的梦想，但许多人称之为“林博国会”。
How does it feel to be part of a majority that's right?
成为一个正确的多数派的一部分感觉如何？
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
It wasn't just the majority they'd gotten. People seem to be signing on to their vision of the country. That it was split into two clear camps. The Democrats were amoral, welfare state-loving, politically correct feminists. Republicans were responsible, balanced, budget-promoting, normal, regular Americans.
他们得到的不仅仅是多数派。人们似乎在签署他们对国家的愿景。它分裂成两个明确的阵营。民主党人是不道德的、热爱福利国家的、政治正确的女权主义者。共和党人是负责任的、平衡的、倡导预算的、正常的、普通的美国人。
One of the questions I was asked as the reporters were peppering me was, do you think Newt will moderate his stance now that he is the Speaker of the House? And I said, better not.
当记者们向我猛烈开火时，我被问到的一个问题是，既然你现在是众议院议长，你认为纽特会缓和他的立场吗？我说，最好不要。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
From the moment Gingrich becomes Speaker, things get pretty red versus blue. One Republican I talked to this week quoted to me from memory, indignant, something ABC News anchor Peter Jennings said on the air when Republicans finally took the House and installed Gingrich as Speaker.
从金里奇成为议长的那一刻起，事情就变得相当红蓝对立。我本周采访的一位共和党人凭记忆愤慨地对我引用了ABC新闻主播彼得·詹宁斯在共和党最终夺得众议院并将金里奇任命为议长时在广播里说的话。
Jennings said the voters had a temper tantrum. The nation can't be run by an angry 2-year-old. This Republican's point was it wasn't just Rush Limbaugh who is stoking the fires of partisan warfare. It was the mainstream media, what he called the liberal media.
詹宁斯说选民发了脾气。国家不能由一个愤怒的2岁孩子管理。这位共和党人的观点是，不仅仅是拉什·林博在煽动党派战争的火焰。还有主流媒体，他所谓的自由派媒体。
It was a new day in Congress. The Speaker and the president-- Gingrich and Clinton-- they did not hang out. The politics that follow are personal and vicious, as I'm sure you know. It's a storm of whitewater, Hillarycare, government shutdown, Vince Foster, impeachment proceedings. Seems like the two sides couldn't stand each other.
国会的新一天。议长和总统——金里奇和克林顿——他们没有聚在一起。随后的政治是个人化和恶毒的，我确信你知道。这是一场白水、希拉里医保、政府关门、文斯·福斯特、弹劾程序的风暴。看起来双方都无法忍受对方。
When Timothy McVeigh blew up a federal office building in Oklahoma City, Clinton gives a speech blaming, in part, talk radio for spreading hate. It was gridlock politics. Depending how you saw it, it was obstructionism for its own sake or obstructionism in defense of bigger ideas that were finally part of the conversation.
当蒂莫西·麦克维炸毁俄克拉荷马城的一座联邦办公大楼时，克林顿发表讲话，部分指责脱口秀广播传播仇恨。这是僵局政治。取决于你如何看待它，这要么是为了阻碍而阻碍，要么是在捍卫终于成为对话一部分的更大理念。
People signed up for red or signed up for blue. Politics is team sports, no compromises. In other words, we've arrived at today.
人们签署了红色或签署了蓝色。政治是团队运动，没有妥协。换句话说，我们到达了今天。
The whole reason I wanted to remind myself of Newt and that time were these past midterm elections. They felt like the extreme sports version of Newt's game plan. Just like he worked really hard to make every Democrat into George McGovern, the campaign that the Republicans ran tried to make every Democrat into a caravan-loving, Kavanaugh-hating Nancy Pelosi.
我想要提醒自己纽特和那个时代全部原因是这些过去的中期选举。它们感觉就像纽特游戏计划的极限运动版本。就像他非常努力地把每一个民主党人都变成乔治·麦戈文一样，共和党人进行的竞选试图把每一个民主党人都变成一个热爱商队、痛恨卡瓦诺的南希·佩洛西。
Newt himself was on Fox a bunch. And his lieutenant--
纽特本人多次出现在福克斯电视台上。还有他的副手——
What an honor. This is so exciting. I have been watching Trump rallies from the very first one.
多么荣幸。这太令人兴奋了。我从特朗普第一次集会开始就一直在看他的集会。
Rush Limbaugh was the opener for Trump's last rally before the midterm vote.
拉什·林博是特朗普中期选举投票前最后一次集会的开场白。
I was just talking to people backstage. And somebody said that the president and all of us have been labeled by some Democrats to the media-- divisive.
我刚才在后台和人们交谈。有人说总统和我们所有人都被一些民主党人贴上了标签——媒体——分裂性的。
[CROWD BOOING]
[人群嘘声]
Divisive? The Democrats haven't even accepted they lost the election in 2016.
分裂性的？民主党人甚至还没有接受他们在2016年输掉选举的事实。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
There is this one moment, where I think Newt realized maybe he'd gone too far in pushing people apart. Stephen Gillon reported the story years later in his book, The Pact.
有这么一个时刻，我认为纽特意识到也许他在推动人们分离时走得太远了。史蒂芬·吉伦多年后在他的书《契约》中报道了这个故事。
It was October 1997. Newt was Speaker. Clinton was president. They wanted to cement their legacies as great men of history.
那是1997年10月。纽特是议长。克林顿是总统。他们想巩固他们作为伟大历史人物的遗产。
They decided to tackle two of the most daunting issues out there-- Medicare and Social Security. Fix them once and for all so they'd be safe for generations to come. The federal budget, for once, was about to run a surplus. Now was the time.
他们决定解决两个最令人生畏的问题——医疗保险和社会保障。一劳永逸地修复它们，使它们能造福子孙后代。联邦预算，破天荒地，即将出现盈余。现在是时候了。
Because they'd fought so publicly, they met in secret. To avoid reporters, Gingrich entered the White House through a side door. If the partisans in either of their parties heard they were working together, the deal would fall apart. The zealots on both teams would punish you for working with the other side.
因为他们打得太公开了，他们秘密会面。为了避开记者，金里奇通过侧门进入白宫。如果他们任何一方的党派人士听说他们正在合作，交易就会破裂。两队的狂热分子都会惩罚你与对方合作。
The deal never happened. Four months after they agreed to work together, the Monica Lewinsky story broke. A few months after that, Gingrich was pushed out of the House. He had to deal with ethics charges, like the Speaker he'd gone after 10 years earlier. And he was really unpopular by then.
交易从未发生。在他们同意合作四个月后，莫妮卡·莱温斯基的故事爆发了。在那之后几个月，金里奇被赶出了众议院。他不得不处理道德指控，就像他10年前对付的议长一样。到那时他已经非常不受欢迎了。
The political environment he'd willed into creation had spit him out. I can't work anymore with these cannibals, he said as he left. But look at him now. He can't stay away.
他意志创造的政治环境已经把他吐了出来。我不能再和这些食人族一起工作了，他在离开时说。但看看现在的他。他无法离开。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our program. Thanks to Steve Kornacki, whose book gave us the idea for this story. His book is called The Red and The Blue The 1990s and the Birth of Political Tribalism.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制作人之一。感谢史蒂夫·科纳基，他的书给了我们这个故事的想法。他的书叫《红色与蓝色：1990年代与政治部落主义的诞生》。
Coming up-- now, I would say that one of our co-workers got the idea to do the story you're going to hear in a minute. He would say he had no choice about that or, for that matter, about anything ever in his life. And he'd say, you don't have a choice either. What the hell he means by that, and he is not kidding. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来——现在，我会说我们的一位同事想到了要做你们马上要听到的这个故事。他会说他在那件事上没有选择，或者，就此而言，他一生中任何事情上都没有选择。他会说，你也没有选择。他那句话是什么鬼意思，而且他不是在开玩笑。一会儿，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on the program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different stories on that theme. Today's show-- where there's a will, stories of people who cannot stop themselves from trying to make things happen the way they think they should happen in this world. We've arrived at Act Two of our program.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你们关于那个主题的不同故事。今天的节目——有志者事竟成，关于那些无法停止尝试按照他们认为应该的方式让事情发生的人的故事。我们到达了我们节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Life is a one-sided coin.
第二幕，生活是一枚单面硬币。
So the entire premise of our show today is where there's a will, which presupposes that we all have a will. That we all have the ability to decide something and take action in the world. But it turns out that there are people who take issue with that premise. And one of them is one of our co-workers here at the radio show, David Kestenbaum. He now presents This Minority Report.
所以我们今天节目整个前提是“有志者事竟成”，这预设了我们都有意志。我们都有能力决定某事并采取行动。但事实证明，有些人对那个前提有异议。他们中的一个是我们在广播节目中的同事，大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。他现在介绍“少数派报告”。
Let me say upfront, I realize the ridiculous, late-night, college-dorm-room nature of what I'm about to say, but here it is. I do not see how free will can exist. By free will, I mean, when you're staring at the menu, and you pick the salad over the burger or any other choice you make-- big or small-- who you marry, whether you keep listening to me for another minute.
让我事先说明，我意识到我即将要说的事情具有荒谬、深夜、大学宿舍的性质，但就是这样。我不明白自由意志怎么可能存在。所谓自由意志，是指当你在盯着菜单，在沙拉和汉堡之间做出选择，或者你做出的任何其他选择——大或小——你嫁给谁，你是否继续听我说话多一分钟。
Free will is the idea that you really get to pick. I'm saying you don't. I don't see how free will can exist.
自由意志是那种你真正能选择的想法。我说你不能。我不明白自由意志怎么可能存在。
I'm somewhat embarrassed to be saying all this. For awhile, I couldn't even talk with my wife about it. It's been on my mind because I was wondering if I should talk about it on the show today.
说这些我有点尴尬。有一段时间，我甚至无法和妻子谈论它。它一直在我的脑海里，因为我在想今天是否应该在节目中谈论它。
And we'd be making the kids' lunches for the next day. There'd be a gap in the conversation. I'd open my mouth, but I just couldn't do it.
我们会为第二天做孩子的午餐。谈话中会出现空白。我张开嘴，但就是做不到。
I don't know why I'm thinking about this now. I think the last time I did was in high school. But I just moved on.
我不知道为什么我现在在想这个。我想我最后一次是在高中时。但我只是继续前进了。
It seems inescapable though. Years ago, I went to grad school in physics. And I think, if you haven't had the experience of actually doing something like that, it's easy to be like, oh, science. There's lots of stuff they don't know.
但这似乎是不可避免的。多年前，我去读物理学研究生。我想，如果你没有真正做过那样的事情，很容易觉得，噢，科学。有很多他们不知道的东西。
But the truth is, we know a lot about how the world was put together. And please excuse the lecturing quality of this. But briefly, there are only four basic forces in the world-- gravity, electromagnetism, and two others, the strong force and the weak force, the first holds atomic nuclei together. The second, crudely speaking, powers the sun.
但事实是，我们对世界是如何组成的了解很多。请原谅这种说教式的语气。简而言之，世界上只有四种基本力——引力、电磁力，以及其他两种，强力与弱力，前者将原子核结合在一起。后者，粗略地说，为太阳提供动力。
Our understanding of these forces has been tested and explored again and again. In one case that sticks with me measured and confirmed to an astounding 12 decimal places. These four forces explain how atoms stick together, how every bit of matter moves, and yes, even the bits of matter that make up us and our brains. We are just collections of atoms.
我们对这些力的理解已经经过一次又一次的测试和探索。有一个例子让我印象深刻，测量并确认到了令人震惊的12位小数。这四种力解释了原子是如何结合在一起的，物质的每一位是如何移动的，是的，甚至构成了我们和我们大脑的那些物质位。我们只是原子的集合。
I don't see how those atoms can truly have any will. When you think you're deciding, I'm going to wear this shirt today, you can't really have decided otherwise. We are subject to the forces of nature, not one of them.
我不明白那些原子怎么能真正拥有任何意志。当你认为你在决定，今天我要穿这件衬衫时，你真的不可能做出其他决定。我们受到自然力的支配，不是其中之一。
It turns out there is this one friend of our family-- hey, Stu-- who also does not see how free will can exist. I was talking to him on the phone, asking if he knew any serious-minded, credentialed people who I could talk to and put on the radio. As it happened, he was staring at his bookshelf. He had a whole collection.
事实证明，我们家有一个朋友——嘿，斯图——他也看不出自由意志怎么可能存在。我在电话里和他交谈，询问他是否认识任何严肃的、有资历的人，我可以与之交谈并放在广播里。巧合的是，他当时正盯着他的书架。他有一整套收藏。
There are books by a bunch of dead philosophers, thinkers of various sorts, and then one book by someone who seemed perfect-- Robert Sapolsky. Sapolsky is a professor at Stanford, Genius Grant recipient. He's a neuroscientist, who also spent 33 summers staring at baboons.
那里有许多已故哲学家的书、各种各样的思想家，还有一本看似完美的人写的书——罗伯特·萨波尔斯基。萨波尔斯基是斯坦福大学的教授，天才奖获得者。他是一位神经科学家，也花了33个夏天盯着狒狒看。
Just last year, he published this big book that was on my friend's shelf, called Behave. So I read it. And there is something curious about it. He seemed to be making the argument that there is no free will. But he never quite came out and said it.
就在去年，他出版了这本在我朋友书架上的大书，叫《行为》。所以我读了它。这里面有些好奇的地方。他似乎在辩称没有自由意志。但他从来没有直接说出来。
The words free will don't even appear until page 580. The first 15 chapters are all about research into what drives human behavior, different parts of the brain, hormones, genetics, how we respond to sensory cues. Was he just avoiding coming out and saying it, like I've been?
自由意志这个词甚至在第580页之前都没有出现。前15章全是关于驱动人类行为的研究，大脑的不同部分、荷尔蒙、遗传学、我们如何对感官线索做出反应。他只是在避免像我一样直接说出来吗？
So you ask this question, can there be free will? But I don't think you directly come out and say what you think. So what do you think?
所以你问这个问题，可以有自由意志吗？但我认为你没有直接说出你的想法。那么你是怎么想的？
I think I was basically trying to be polite there and sort of a good house guest. In actuality, I don't think there is room for the slightest bit of free will out there.
我想我基本上是在试图表现得礼貌，有点像个好客人。实际上，我认为外面没有一点点自由意志的空间。
Sapolsky said, this was, in fact, the entire reason he had written the book. He was trying to lead people slowly along a gentle path to this uncomfortable idea. I was reading it right.
萨波尔斯基说，这实际上是他写这本书的全部原因。他试图引导人们慢慢走上一条通往这个令人不舒服的想法的平缓道路。我读得很对。
I asked him why he doesn't believe we have free will. As a neuroscientist, he thinks about it this way. Take any action-- a movement of your eyebrow, something you say. Just trace that thing back. Behind anything like that are just some muscles that moved.
我问他为什么不相信我们有自由意志。作为一名神经科学家，他是这样想的。采取任何行动——眉毛的移动，你说的话。顺着这件事追溯回去。任何类似的事情背后都只是几块肌肉在移动。
So let's simplify it. A muscle did something. Meaning a neuron in your motor cortex commanded your muscle to do that. That neuron fired only because it got inputs from umpteen other neurons milliseconds before.
让我们简化它。肌肉做了一些动作。意味着你运动皮层中的一个神经元命令你的肌肉做那个。那个神经元之所以放电，仅仅是因为它在几毫秒前得到了来自其他无数神经元的输入。
And those neurons only fired because they got inputs milliseconds before and back and back and back. Show me one neuron anywhere in this pathway that, from out of nowhere, decided to say something that activated in ways that are not explained by the laws of the physical universe, and ions, and channels, and all that sort of stuff. Show me one neuron that has some cellular semblance of free will. And there is no such neuron.
而那些神经元之所以放电，仅仅是因为它们在几毫秒前得到了输入，如此往复。给我展示一下这条通路中任何一个神经元，它凭空决定说出某些东西，以不受物理宇宙规律、离子、通道以及所有那类东西解释的方式激活。给我展示一个拥有某种细胞层面的自由意志外观的神经元。没有这样的神经元。
Your emotions, consciousness-- same argument. At the bottom, just cells and chemicals acting like they would in the lab.
你的情绪、意识——同样的论点。在底层，只有细胞和化学物质像在实验室里那样行动。
There's nothing more or less than the mechanics.
没有多一点或少一点，只有机制。
I mean, I feel like your whole book could have actually just been two sentences to cut to the chase, you know, not that I didn't enjoy the other chapters. What does it actually mean not to have free will? Do you think of it as, if you rewind the clock, it would all unfold the same way?
我的意思是，我觉得你的整本书其实完全可以只有两句话来切入正题，你知道，不是我没享受其他章节。没有自由意志实际上意味着什么？你认为它是，如果你倒带时钟，它都会以同样的方式展开吗？
Basically, it's got to mean that.
基本上，它一定意味着那个。
I should say, there is some debate about whether no free will means that if you went back in time, and let your life unfold again, you would make all the same decisions exactly the same way. The reason there's some debate is that way down at the subatomic level, there does seem to be a little wellspring of randomness.
我应该说，关于没有自由意志是否意味着如果你回到过去，让你的生活再次展开，你会完全以同样的方式做出所有决定，存在一些争论。争论的原因是，深入到亚原子层面，似乎确实存在一点随机性的源泉。
Quantum mechanics is all about probabilities. Like when a radioactive atom breaks apart, the exact moment it happens seems random. It's unclear how often this apparent subatomic randomness escapes into the larger world. But it could be that if you rewound the film of life and played it forward again, you might get a different movie. But it wouldn't be because of free will. It would just be subatomic randomness messing with the plot.
量子力学全是关于概率的。就像放射性原子分解时，它发生的精确时刻似乎是随机的。这种明显的亚原子随机性有多少逃逸到更大的世界还不清楚。但有可能是，如果你倒带生活的电影并再次向前播放，你可能会得到一部不同的电影。但那不是因为自由意志。那只是亚原子随机性在搅乱情节。
A friend of mine had this experience where he kind of got to test this out. His brain was artificially rolling back the clock, and he got to see its machine-like nature. He went ice skating, and he fell and hit his head, which gave him some temporary amnesia.
我的一个朋友有过这样的经历，他算是测试了一下。他的大脑在人为地倒带时钟，他看到了它像机器一样的本质。他去滑冰，跌倒撞到了头，这让他有了一些暂时的失忆。
When he was on the stretcher, he asked what had happened. His wife said, you fell and hit your head. And he made this joke. That's not how you want to leave the ice. But then he kept asking what had happened and making the same joke, like, oh, I fell on the ice. I know a good joke to make here.
当他在担架上时，他问发生了什么事。他妻子说，你摔倒撞到了头。他开了个玩笑。那不是你想离开冰面的方式。但他一直问发生了什么事，并开了同样的玩笑，比如，噢，我摔在冰上了。我知道这里有个好笑话可以说。
After, he said it was like opening up the hard drive of his mind and seeing inside. He's fine now, by the way.
事后，他说就像打开了他大脑的硬盘，看到了里面一样。顺便说一句，他现在没事。
For me, it is the one scientific fact about the world that I am just not OK with. I'm fine with the big bang and that all of existence came from a tiny point. That doesn't faze me anymore. But I am not OK with the idea that I don't have free will. That seems-- I can't give that up. If I give that up, I'm giving up everything.
对我来说，这是关于世界的一个科学事实，我只是不能接受。我没问题接受大爆炸，所有的存在都来自一个微小的点。那不再困扰我了。但我不能接受我没有自由意志的想法。那似乎——我不能放弃那个。如果我放弃那个，我放弃了一切。
I know. It's really, really hard.
我知道。这真的，真的很困难。
I feel like I'm deciding to say what I say right now. I feel pretty confident about that. When I think I'm making a decision, what am I actually doing?
我觉得我在决定说我现在说的话。我觉得很自信。当我认为我在做决定时，我实际上在做什么？
Well, there's just a whole bunch of neuronal fulcra and some sort of Rube Goldberg sort of stretch of things that teeter this way or that and as a result, bounce something else in another direction.
嗯，只是有一大堆神经元的支点和某种鲁布·戈德堡式的延伸，向这边或那边摇摆，结果，把别的东西弹向了另一个方向。
So while it feels like we could choose this or maybe that, the truth is, some set of events mechanically led to our final decision. We just aren't aware of it. Sapolsky brought of this famous experiment.
所以虽然感觉我们可以选择这个或那个，事实是，一套事件机械地导致了我们最终的决定。我们只是没意识到而已。萨波尔斯基提出了这个著名的实验。
Sit somebody down in the room and ask them to name their favorite detergent. And who knows what they're going to come up with. Do the same thing, and there's a picture of the ocean in the room on the wall. And they're now significantly more likely to say Tide. Tide's my favorite detergent.
让某人坐在房间里，让他们说出他们最喜欢的清洁剂。谁知道他们会想到什么。做同样的事，房间的墙上挂着一张海洋的图片。他们现在明显更有可能说泰德（Tide）。泰德是我最喜欢的清洁剂。
And ask them why. And they will give you some [? Foucauldian ?] rational explanation about what Tide does to their strawberry stains on their shirts.
问他们为什么。他们会给你一些（傅柯式的）理性的解释，关于泰德对他们衬衫上草莓污渍的作用。
Sapolsky says, when we think we are making a decision, it is basically just some more complicated version of that. You were looking at the menu. The room was slightly warm. Your shoes were wet from the rain. The light above the table was just so, and so you picked the salad.
萨波尔斯基说，当我们认为我们在做决定时，它基本上只是那个更复杂的版本。你正看着菜单。房间稍微有点暖和。你的鞋子被雨淋湿了。桌子上的灯光刚刚好，所以你选了沙拉。
The mom who yells at the army general couldn't have done it any other way. Newt Gingrich, when he got to Congress-- same thing. Speaking of which, did we all just go and vote? Choose our representatives?
那个对军队将军大吼大叫的母亲不可能以任何其他方式做它。纽特·金里奇，当他进入国会时——同样的事情。说到这个，我们都去投票了吗？选择我们的代表？
If you believe what I'm saying, no one really could have decided to choose differently. And look, I'm not saying, don't vote. You should vote. Do good things. Be kind. Give to charity.
如果你相信我说的话，没人能真正决定选择不同的方式。看，我不是说，不要投票。你应该投票。做好的事情。友善。捐赠慈善。
I'm just saying, it's weird. We are machines that don't know it, but don't want to deal with it.
我只是说，这很奇怪。我们是不知道它，但不想处理它的机器。
For Sapolsky, this idea that we don't have free will is truly profound and should change the way we think about lots of things. For instance, all those decisions you've made because you're a good person, all those things you're proud of-- don't be so proud. Anyone else starting with your atoms in the same place would have done the same thing.
对于萨波尔斯基，我们没有自由意志这个想法确实很深刻，应该改变我们思考很多事情的方式。例如，所有那些因为你是一个好人而做出的决定，所有那些你引以为豪的事情——不要那么骄傲。任何其他人从你原子所在的同一个地方开始，都会做同样的事情。
When people do bad things, he says you shouldn't hate them. Probably also, he says, we should try to rethink the entire justice system, which, of course, is a weird thing to say since there is no trying.
当人们做坏事时，他说你不应该恨他们。他说，大概我们还应该尝试重新思考整个司法系统，当然，这很奇怪，因为根本没有“尝试”这回事。
It's just such a crazy-making idea, you know?
这真是一个让人发疯的想法，你知道吗？
Yup.
是的。
Are you OK with it?
你还好吗？
Not in the slightest. If I stop and really think about it, I get slightly panicked. There is no way to get out of an existential morass if you start really thinking about this stuff.
一点也不。如果我停下来真正想一想，我会稍微恐慌。如果你开始真正思考这些东西，就没有办法走出存在主义的困境。
How often do you find yourself thinking about it?
你多久会发现自己在思考它？
Oh, I don't know, maybe four or five times an hour. This is all I think about these days.
噢，我不知道，也许一小时四五次。这些天我满脑子都是这个。
It's amazing to me that scientists don't talk about this more. I think I went my entire graduate career testing the fundamental laws of nature without it ever coming up.
科学家们不更多地谈论这个让我感到惊讶。我想我的整个研究生生涯都在测试自然的基本规律，却从未提到过它。
Hi. How are you?
嗨。你好吗？
How was the exam, the midterm?
期中考试考得怎么样？
This is Melissa Franklin, professor of physics at Harvard. And for years, she was my professor. I talked to her for the show when I was grappling with the possibility that we might be alone in the universe. So she seemed like the logical choice for this question.
这是梅丽莎·富兰克林，哈佛大学的物理学教授。多年来，她一直是我的老师。当我纠结于我们可能在宇宙中孤独的可能性时，我为节目采访了她。所以她看起来是这个问题的逻辑选择。
This is how you think about it too, right, that we can't possibly have free will?
这也是你思考它的方式，对吧，我们不可能有自由意志？
I think that there's no evidence that we have free will. I mean, I guess it's possible. It seems unlikely. It seems like we have free will.
我认为没有证据表明我们有自由意志。嗯，我想这是可能的。这看起来不太可能。看起来好像我们有自由意志。
That's the thing, right?
这就是重点，对吧？
Yeah. So I was asking one of my colleagues today, do you believe in free will? And he says, absolutely. And I said, do you think our brains are made up of neurons and axons and things? He said, yes.
是的。所以今天我问我的一位同事，你相信自由意志吗？他说，绝对相信。我说，你认为我们的大脑是由神经元、轴突之类的东西组成的吗？他说，是的。
And then I said, so how do you reconcile those two things? And he said, if it walks like free will and quacks like free will, it's free will.
然后我说，那你怎么协调这两件事？他说，如果它看起来像自由意志，叫起来像自由意志，它就是自由意志。
So our word is wrong?
所以我们的词是错的？
No, the point is that operationally, we appear to have free will.
不，重点是操作上，我们似乎有自由意志。
But it's wrong.
但它是错的。
Yes, yes, it is wrong. But it seems like we do, so why not just go with the flow? That's the idea.
是的，是的，它是错的。但看起来我们有，所以为什么不顺其自然呢？这就是那个想法。
She was at lunch when this conversation happened. And immediately, another colleague jumped in to argue the other side.
当这次谈话发生时，她正在吃午饭。另一个同事立刻跳出来争论另一方。
And the other person was just saying, you're an idiot, without saying the word idiot. It's one of these things when you start to talk about things that you don't want to think about that you sort of hope that magic comes in some way.
另一个人只是在说，你是个白痴，没说那个白痴词。这就是当你开始谈论你不想思考的事情时，你有点希望魔法以某种方式进来的事情之一。
So one of them was saying, well, there could be some complex thing that comes in that actually gives us free will. And the other person was saying, you're talking about magic or God. Just say it out loud-- magic or God.
所以其中一个人说，可能有一些复杂的魔法进来，实际上给了我们自由意志。另一个人说，你在谈论魔法或上帝。大声说出来——魔法或上帝。
Melissa is actually OK with the idea of not having free will.
梅丽莎实际上可以接受没有自由意志的想法。
I think maybe the problem of just a machine is not a nice way of thinking about it. A human is not just a machine. A human is an amazing machine.
我想可能仅仅是一个机器的问题不是思考它的好方式。人类不仅仅是一个机器。人类是一个令人惊叹的机器。
Yeah, I know. I love the machine that is my wife and my two little machines. They're really adorable. But when I think about it, that's what they are. They're so cute, though.
是的，我知道。我爱那个是我的妻子的机器和我两个小机器。它们真的很可爱。但当我想到它时，那就是它们。不过它们很可爱。
I go back and forth on what to do with this information. Sometimes I feel like Robert Sapolsky does. That this is something deeply profound. We are machines that are smart enough to have figured that out, to realize we probably can't have free will.
我反复思考如何处理这些信息。有时我觉得像罗伯特·萨波尔斯基那样。这是一个非常深刻的事情。我们是聪明的机器，已经弄清楚了这一点，意识到我们可能不能有自由意志。
And so we should think about what that means for how we organize our society, how we treat other people. But there is another part of me that feels like maybe it changes nothing at all, which is weird to know that we are all living with this illusion of free will, but somehow doesn't matter. I've come to think of my daily existence as kind of like being in a movie, where I'm just along for the ride.
所以我们应该思考这意味着我们如何组织我们的社会，我们如何对待其他人。但我的另一部分感觉它可能什么都没改变，这很奇怪，知道我们都生活在这种自由意志的幻觉中，但不知何故没关系。我已经开始认为我的日常生活就像在一部电影里一样，我只是跟着坐车。
I'm making choices all day long. But the machine that is me couldn't really have chosen anything else. It gives me a weird lightness when I think about it that way. And if I'm being honest, it also feels kind of cool knowing this thing that no one wants to face up to, watching us all run around as if not true.
我整天都在做选择。但那个是我的机器不可能真正选择其他任何东西。当我那样想它时，它给了我一种奇怪的轻盈感。如果我诚实的话，知道这个没人愿意面对的事实，看着我们所有人跑来跑去，就好像这不是真的，也感觉很酷。
When you pick a song to listen to, when you decide to try a second date, when you go left instead of right, when I say something stupid instead of just sitting and thinking for a moment, when I pick what picture to draw on my son's lunch bag, those aren't really choices. But I'm good at living with contradictions. It's in the machinery.
当你选择一首歌听时，当你决定尝试第二次约会时，当你向左而不是向右走时，当我说一些愚蠢的话而不是坐下来思考一会时，当我选择在儿子的午餐袋上画什么画时，那些都不是真正的选择。但我很擅长与矛盾共存。它在机制里。
Our show was produced today by David Kestenbaum. The people who put our show together include Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Jarrett Floyd, Damien Grave, Michele Harris, Chana-Joffe Walt, Seth Lind, Ana Martin, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katharine Mae Mondo, Robyn Semien and Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala and Diane Wu, our senior producer, Brian Reed, our managing editor, Susan Burton.
我们的节目今天由大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆制作。把我们的节目放在一起的人包括佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、贾瑞特·弗洛伊德、达米安·格雷夫、米歇尔·哈里斯、查纳-乔菲·沃尔特、塞思·林德、安娜·马丁、米基·米克、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·梅·蒙多、罗宾·塞米恩和艾丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和戴安·吴，我们的高级制作人，布莱恩·里德，我们的主编，苏珊·伯顿。
Special thanks today to Rob Long, Kelefa Sanneh, Stu Greenberg, Sean Carroll, Jim Naureckas, Charlie Schaupp, Stephen Talbot. And thanks to the Frontline documentary, The Long March of Newt Gingrich, our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free.
今天特别感谢罗伯·朗、凯勒法·桑内、斯图·格林伯格、肖恩·卡罗尔、吉姆·诺雷卡斯、查理·肖普、史蒂芬·塔尔博特。感谢Frontline纪录片，《纽特·金里奇的长征》，我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以完全免费听我们超过600集的档案。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. And as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. I said, Torey, we've got 30 seconds left in the program. What should we do?
《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交换中心传送到公共广播电台。一如既往地，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。我说，托里，我们节目还剩30秒。我们该做什么？
Just shut up. Shut up. Shut up now. Don't talk about it anymore. Shut up.
闭嘴。闭嘴。现在闭嘴。别再提这事了。闭嘴。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。